[Musique]
magnifique l'affairé je suis le plus
ancien contrôleur de la tour eiffel je
suis fier je suis là depuis beaucoup
d'années et je me plais très bien le
faire alors je suis toujours entraîneur
je vous présente ma meilleure amie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis très bien très sympathique
mépris célèbre c'est moi je faisais la
stabilité la tour eiffel 74 ans il faut
pointer toujours sur lecture parce que
je n'ai pas cette langue blair
l'ambiance qui me plaît tout ça alors
quand je ne travaille pas je m'ennuie
alors je viens les aider pour la saison
maintenant seulement six mois avez-vous
le vertige
aulas dans le ventre non d'autant que
j'étais sa petite quelquefois des
incidents au vous savez il ya des gens
des gens qui sont malades des gens
la valascia là il tombe là alors là on a
deux morts on les aide
l'ebit pagnes des panneaux rugueux fois
lors de la 10 20 minutes 30 minutes deux
fois trente minutes c'est très long
alors oui mais que voulez-vous alors la
chance à des gens de ce match et les
suicides sur la tour eiffel
allégé de ça maintenant non mais avant
il ya eu beaucoup
moi je n'ai vu depuis
pensez vous 150 dans moi j'avais tout de
même des grille protectrice envers une
adolescence et foley suscité par les
gens se suicident pas et maintenant il
s'est dit plus haut non quand même y en
a eu il ya pas longtemps qui j'ai
déjeuné quand même le mac il fait alors
ils ont alors un troisième plateforme en
dessous par là même sur mon nom je le
magasin
là où j'habite et vous savez vous
distinguez vous regardez les jupons et
en temps en temps un peu dont les
bénévoles a brillé mais j'avais un peu
vain mais pour le savoir puisque joseph
vous regarder sans doute envolé de 9 ans
évoque les regardant ça je n'avais pas
salé des minijupes jusque-là jeu
formidable
alors là oui on travaille au les jolies
femmes
ça me donne le vertige
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
olala jan breydel alejo il ya des pattes
en l'air c'est la vivent les corners
[Applaudissements]
société de la tour eiffel sentiment
situation très gêné si la sortie de ce
côté jeune homme sorti paris elle dépend
de la courtoisie il a pas beaucoup de
sel oui mais dans le fond là va en voir
un très bien jusqu'au niveau 1
oui c'est bien ici à bâle et du tout 74
ans bientôt un les fonctionnaires pas un
seul os que je suis bien et puis je me
réfère je vais mourir bientôt ne sais
pas coucou revoilà
oui mesdames valent à la corde d'un gris
mais après ça peut pas tout le monde ça
yalouz au long je préfère l'ancien
couleurs de 10 de légende a été de 2,2
les nationalités et vous comprenez
ce qui me donne je vous avais pour le
travail que j'ai affalé le changement de
schengen mais niasse des lobbies riffs
des choses comme ça n'est ce pas
justement demande à prendre un plancher
langue italienne espagnole avec catalan
ferran
qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'est ce que
vous demandez pas les acheter les
terrains à catillon molyneux dames sacré
coeur il se montre très discret lait
d'uniterre
oui j'avais dans l'ensemble mais quand
même et jean très content quand ils
peuvent conseiller quelqu'un qui parle
la langue se transformer les enfants qui
fait un peu cliché comme andy murray en
deux il meuble et du monde junior en
asie mais saint amé tenir compte s'il
vous plaît mais cela est sûre si vous
voulez sincère non il me l'a dit yens et
même pas la radio et visiteurs vous
sentir mais leur ville fondée par je me
suis un petit peu mais je leur réponds
comme il faut laisse pas toujours
gentiment le jour et le montage de 114
me sens bien je pense qu'en ce moment je
prends mon peine yala et un coup et
voilà je voudrais aller chercher et tout
va bien les arts a cherché pour enfin
une belle chanson challenge c'est ben
beau profil c'est encore moi
[Rires]
un but marqué
[Musique]
après mon avis il ya 30 ans n'avait
jamais gagné et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]